in blowing up russia former kgb agent
alexander litvinenko takes on vladimir
putin and russian espionage he claims
that the russian president is using
secret service operatives to maintain
control of the country
mr litvinenko was poisoned in 2006 and
passed away three weeks later
next on book tv co-author yerry
felstinsky claims that the poisoning was
due to mr litvinenko's collaboration on
this book
this is just under an hour
great uh thank you very much uh louis
the way the way that we thought we would
do this is by
uh yuri and i uh talking
between ourselves if you like for about
20 minutes or so before we throw this
open to uh q a
the um
the book i might say i think my role to
say is absolutely terrific and uh it's
also a very timely book because uh
russian politics have
always been something of a mystery we
all know the the rather grand uh
remark about winston the winston
churchill made about enigmas raptor
mysteries and so on but the much better
remark he made is that trying to
understand what's going on in the
kremlin is like watching two dogs
fighting under a carpet and um
we really don't know uh in in in the
1990s russia in the early 1990s under
yeltsin uh you had perhaps an earlier
model of russia the you know google's
image of the troika going madly you're
not quite sure where it was going but
what a spectacle it was
uh since putin came to power the
the ice seems to be once again freezing
and
i don't think anyone quite knows
what to make of him or it
friend or foe i think all we do know is
that
next time george bush looks into
someone's eyes and sees their soul
he might need to be a little bit more
discriminating
i think
the book which is banned in russia
abandoned boss not banned in boston but
banned in russia
uh
is
the key to the book and i think
something that's worth just beginning
the discussion with because it is
central
uh is the explosions
that in many ways uh became the way that
um
the putin
came to power uh they made him they were
the court they were allegedly the well
they became used as the cause of the war
in chechnya and the nationalist fervor
that that whipped up took him very
easily into power
uh
perhaps we might begin yuri with you
talking just a tiny bit about those
explosions
well let me first say that uh
i'm a historian and i wrote several
books and usually when you finish the
book this is kind of the end of the
story
uh with this
particular book uh
everything is different uh indeed when
the book was finished that's when the
story actually
started and when then
that's when things started to happen and
this was of course a very uh you know
new experience for me this was never
uh
expected uh we met with alexander in
moscow in uh
98.
and we had
fairly close relations uh you have to
understand that uh lithuanian car was
working for kgb all his life
and
when we met he
just started to have problems with the
garment he started to have problems with
the
government and with the russian secret
service
because he went public uh with a very
damaging information for the russian
secret service again this never happened
before there were cases when defectors
of course defected from their soviet
secret service from kgb
but it never happened when a person from
the russian secret service publicly
would
you know uh uh during two hours press
conference would tell uh you know
stories to to a russian public and
that's exactly what happened in in 1988
um
because of this he was fired from the
fsb the fsb of course is a new name for
the old kgb
the russian security services uh he then
was put in prison for nine months
released uh by the end of 99 that's when
we met i was in moscow in 98 99
in 2000 uh i started to investigate as a
researcher
the september 99 boomings in
russia
again now unfortunately because of all
major
terrorist acts uh
recently we became very
cynical uh but in september of 99 this
was a major terrorist act uh 300 people
killed four apartment buildings were
blown up
two of them in moscow and moscow is a
very special place in in russia
russia is actually a country of one two
cities
and um it uh
became obvious for for many people uh
i was not the first one and the only one
who suggested that the russian secret
service might be behind
but i probably was the the you know the
only one who started to investigate it
as a historian as a serious researcher
on the level of a book
and
i realized that there is some pieces of
information like in a puzzle uh which uh
you know which i cannot get as a
historian i could not get those answers
i need somebody who will tell me what's
happening inside whether first of all
whether it's possible that in
99 a group of people from the russian
secret service because we are talking
about a group of people would blow up
buildings in russia and chop them in
moscow killing several hundred people
and i realized that alexander is the
only person who probably
would trust me enough
and will be honest with me enough to
help me to answer those questions so in
uh 2000 i went to
moscow for the last time this was
september of 2000
uh to meet alexander to tell him
that i'm
writing a book about explosions that i
have very difficult questions which i
want him to answer and to ask him
whether he actually
would agree to write this book together
with me
and uh
we had very long conversation in the
middle of the night
for several hours
discussing whether
you know what he thinks about explosions
what he knows about explosions whether
we could write this book together and
basically he agreed of course uh then we
saw that well he told me that you know
you're in boston i'm in moscow how we're
going to write this book
i said well
you know i guess it's time for you
to get out from this country because
you have no future here anyway and he
indeed didn't have any future it was
just a matter of time before he will be
put in prison again or killed again and
i told him look you know you have to
think about yourself you have to think
about your family you know that you're
working for them for many many years
uh you know that they will
never pardon you and you probably know
that unless you
you know immigrate
you probably will be dead anyway
and uh the problem was that he didn't
have foreign passport and of course you
cannot leave russia if you do not have
foreign passport and indeed he was even
prohibited to leave moscow
and i told him look
you know
your job is to cross the border because
that's where i cannot help you the
moment you cross across the board i will
pick you up and that's exactly what
happened to the conversation again took
place on 23rd of uh september two weeks
later i got telephone call uh telling me
that he crossed the border and i picked
him up then we're very quickly we were
very efficient very quickly organized
the escape of his family
they had foreign passports so it was
much easier
and
on the first of november 2000 uh what is
very important i think uh
he landed in london on the 1st of
november 2006 exactly six years later
he was poisoned and uh
when the russian secret service plans
operation it's it's uh all this you know
it's a project it's an event it's
something you know big something unusual
you know they would never use the same
killing machine
twice so the same
poisoning twice the same method twice
it's for for them it's like a theatrical
performance
and i'm quite sure that those people who
were playing this operation uh
conducted it on first of november for
purpose because they knew that that's
exactly six years when litwink arrived
to
to london
now uh the question which is uh going to
be asked and that's why i will address
it right now
why is it so obvious
that
they were using polonium to poison
between nanka radioactive material which
is easy to trace et cetera et cetera
it's not obvious and it's not so they
were using a radioactive poisoning in
russia inside russia several times this
is obvious there are several people who
were killed
and definitely with a radioactive
poisonings
they are not traceable uh we are talking
about different kind of radiation
there's a so-called alpha radiation it's
very short it's
half
one centimeter of you know half inch
long it's
basically untraceable there is no
equipment i mean there is now
but until november 2006 there was no
equipment in britain to
to find this radiation uh the fact that
we know about this now is a scientific
miracle we know this for several reasons
number one
unlike everybody else who was poisoned
with radioactive poisonings lithuanian
did not die within a first or second
week as usual was happening he was
holding for 23 days no one knows why
two hours before his death one of
british specialists who were around him
send his liquids to a nuclear station in
britain this was the only place where
they had lab which was able to measure
liquid for for alpharadiation now
alpha radiation could be uh
found only in liquid so if the person is
already dead there is no way you would
be able to establish that he was
poisoned with radioactive material
without affirmation etc so the fact that
we know everything and now we know
everything because it is a radiation
it's an alpha radiation but it is
radiation is a miracle this was never
expected this was never planned
and if lithuanian would die just a day
before like on 22nd of november this
would be a suspicious death under
suspicious circumstances and the case
would be closed
so uh
the
uh this book unfortunately
happened to be a very important book i
think uh
there were several people uh
who were connected to this book one way
or another killed uh several of them
three of them inside russia lithuanian
kofkos was killed in london and uh
the importance of this book i think is
is the following uh
russia is going to be with us whether we
like it or dislike it whether it will
change
or it will stay as it is now russia is
going to be with us forever and we will
have to coexist with russia for forever
and for this reason i think it's very
important to understand
what's going on in russia who is ruling
there who is controlling this country
what's actually happening there
and when we uh
finish this manuscript and the
manuscript was finished in 2001
no one i have to be you know open with
you no one actually wanted to publish
this book no one wanted to publish this
book because it was too dark
uh people were saying that look you know
you're probably not objective you're
stating that the russian secret service
is trying to take political power in
russia
and it is
probably not so and if things are so bad
why are you guys still alive
by the fact that they killed lithuanian
because they kind of prove that
whatever is written there is probably is
is a real story
and uh
that's why now publishers do not have
problems to to believe this book and to
publish this because now they do not
want to be nice to putin they do not
want to be nice to russia and
they really care uh to to understand
what's happening in russia and what's
happening in russia
i'm afraid is that the russian secret
service and again this never happened
before where usually we're dealing with
political parties whether they are
democrats or republicans communists or
fascists but this for political parties
which would have control political
control over the political life or
economic life of the country in russia
for the first time in history
uh we have a russian secret service of
the russian
security services controlling of the
whole country it's it's a new phenomena
no one knows how to deal with it
and it's very dangerous because those
people unfortunately and these are the
same people who were working for kgb all
their life
under the soviet regime those people do
not really know how to build they know
how to destroy to kill to control
uh well now they're using money so to
buy because now of course russia is a
very rich country because of uh just
uh
prices right for for oil and gas so now
they're using money as a weapon as well
but if they do not
if they are not able to control or to
buy they kill because this is still
organizations of killers and that's the
instinct is to to kill if they're not
able to control
and that's that's why i think it is very
important to to understand
what's what's happening in russia now
because
you know if the russian secret service
is controlling the country and i believe
they are
then we are talking about uh
you know
organization like similar to gestapo
control and post nazi germany it's it's
uh
it's a very very tragic situation for
for russians as well uh because there is
uh
no freedom of press anymore uh you know
we may like yeltsin i hate yeltsin but
under yeltsin from 91 to 99 the freedom
of press really existed in russia and
journalists were writing what they
wanted and yeltsin had two percent
popularity but he had those two percent
popularity because journalists were
allowed to write what they want now of
course yeltsin have like has 75 or
whatever
of popularity but there is no freedom of
speech so there is no way actually to
measure his popularity
uh so russia changed russia changed from
2000 to 2006 very quickly very
dramatically
that's why the book is published now and
it is going by the end of these years
it's going to be published in
approximately 20 languages in
approximately 20 countries and uh
i think it's a very interesting book
i think i will end now and uh we'll ask
you know all questions which you might
have
yes
no we haven't we have a microphone
there
excuse me
left uh soviet union or they call them
in the united states former state union
in 1978 you return to russia in 1998
for 20 years you did not see mr um
alexandre latinenko and at the same time
you make a statement but you know him
very well did you have some kind of uh
relationship with him these 20 years
what you used to live or no continue to
live in the united states once again
it's my first question my second
question is
mr litvinyanka never was by any standard
not by russian standard not by united
states standard dissident he had a very
very low position in former kgb or fsb
why do you think
he
will be killed by president of
russia a person who has a very very low
position in kgb in my last uh statement
about percentage wise what you said
popularity
uh mr
putin by standard is four times more
popular in russia than president of
united states in the united states
so
what i personally also know what mr
litvinyanka had a history of psychiatric
problem i just finished to glance
introduction in your book and i want you
to know did he have psychiatric problem
is it true or not okay uh
let's let's start from the last one i no
it's not true i he did not have any
psychiatric problems trust me he was
absolutely normal i would you know i
wish myself to be as normal as he is
uh now lithuanian cause that's how i
started i believe lithuanian was working
for kgb all his life he was never
dissident he never claimed that he is
dissident uh he hold the position uh
of lieutenant colonel with this with the
russian secret service with fsb uh
whether it's low or high do not know
president putin holds the same position
he was lieutenant colonel uh the
popularity again we discussed that
yeltsin had two percent whatever super
saiyan because there was a freedom of
press i think mr bush has the same
problem as if he has freedom of press in
this country that's why his popularity
is much lower than mr putin's you know
brezhnev had high popularity of course
than putin
sadat in inject i remember had 99
popularity so it's uh you you you know
you understand quite well how to deal
with the percentage uh i met lithuanian
in 98 again what's important to
understand that when you deal with
people from kid gb i usually try to
avoid the word trust friendship etc
these are very special people who were
trained you know for a particular job
for a particular
organization uh when i say that uh you
know he trusted me this was important
because until 98 when he
you know defected from the kgb from the
fsb he actually was not allowed to see
foreigners and in my case he had a
foreigner who of course was speaking
russian this was much easier for him so
i probably was the first foreigner he
ever seen in his life and
uh we spent
many many days and weeks together during
those
you know 1998. so i think he trusted me
this was important otherwise he would
not talk to me
yes
there was another high profile poisoning
and i was speaking of fuscinko
what are your thoughts on the
implications uh do you think uh
the former uh soviet union do you think
russia the kremlin
uh fsb was involved in the poisoning
attempt of on yushenko i i think the war
i i think uh mr yusing of course knows
this i i think he knows uh as many
details as uh could be you know obtained
in in poisoning like this
and i personally believe that there was
a political deal struck between uh
yushing and putin that this uh you know
questions is not
this question is not discussed anymore
at least is not discussed publicly but
if you ask my personal opinion yes i
think mr yusinko was poisoned by the
russian secret services this was done of
course uh during his campaign for
presidency when another candidate who is
uh you know
who was supported by russia was very
close to win and i i think the decision
you know if we
uh
kind of try to see it from the russian
point of view the decision to
take yushinka out of the race was a very
practical decision to to try to hold
ukraine within the
sphere of entrance of russia and uh you
know we know that they were very close
to to actually to to win that battle and
i think it's fair also to say that and
that there's another poisoning too or
attempted poisoning off the
very brave
russian journalist who was recently shot
um but before then she went down to
chechnya
and had an unexplained
sickness which basically was poisonous
right right as this happened when she
was trying to to go to bislan to
negotiate the release of hostages and
the russian secret service wanted her to
prevent uh
of course from doing this because
uh the she was so respected by chechens
that it was clear that if she would
manage to to try to negotiate the deal
there is going to be probably a very
good chance for terrorists to release to
release hostages and the russian
secretary didn't want to do it and uh
later anna politkovska who who whom i
knew quite well and to be
you know we had very
warm and nice relations she she was
gunned down killed in moscow on
2nd of october 2006 uh really one month
before litmuanka was killed and this was
i have to stress the birthday of
vladimir putin uh meaning that
whoever was killing her
knew that he is going to make this
present for the president and knew that
president putin will like it because you
see again you could kill her on 6th of
october on an 8th of october and nothing
would
be changed by that
but people again people who were
preparing that murder knew that
putin probably will like this present
uh i i have to uh to address by the way
one of uh your questions which i missed
i uh
so far i i never stated that president
putin was behind the murder of alexandre
litwinienko and indeed uh the the reason
for this is that
we do not really know i mean that at
this point uh we do not know whether it
was uh mr putin who gave the order to
kill it winyanka or the the head of the
russian secret service who is mr
partnership
i i think sooner or later we might come
to to the uh certain conclusion or may
have some information about this but i
think what's important uh
also again we do not have any
facts to to claim that we know that
putin was behind the murder we do see
how mr putin behaves after this murder
took place we do know that the russian
government uh is
not cooperating uh
so speaking with the british authorities
uh we see how the russian government uh
try to actually
put the blame towards the british side
and this of course uh
is uh done only because mr putin
approves whatever happening now because
he's in control
of the station and those people of
course are doing exactly what he's
instructing them to do
aside from lipvinienko what other
sources are you using what sort of facts
or hard evidence do you have or is this
chiefly based on your conversations with
lip and yinkle well uh
once again i was not the first one and
the only one who suggested that the
russian secret service was behind the
boomings i uh use i i'm if i should say
fairly good historian so i used uh a lot
of open source materials a lot of them
thousands and dozens of thousands of
pages literally
but
you see what's important is
that even when you get together all
these facts and even uh when you see
that the russian secret service it seems
to be behind those buildings
and again
you may believe this book you may not
believe that what we are not talking
about serious this is not a series it's
a fact and there is nothing really
nothing what
could uh
you know push you to to a different
direction i mean there is no other syria
because there is a claim of cause by the
russian government that chechens were
behind the bombings but there is no
evidence no supporting evidence at all
to those claims uh nothing exists except
for for this book actually uh
so that this was not the problem the
problem was that you see in lithuanian
received an order in 97 to kill
berezovsky but instead of killing
berezovsky he came to berezovsky told
him openly that he received this order
uh in 99 a group of people received an
order to blow up buildings but instead
of
you know going public with this
information they
actually destroy those buildings you see
lithuanian wasn't in
the same position he had a choice he he
could kill the resolve skin continue to
circle for kgb
or you know he could
try to change the history
of events and he did indeed
uh so that's what i was trying to
understand how could it possible that in
99 a group of people
oh that's okay they work for kgb but
this is 99 this is moscow and they're
blowing up buildings it's difficult to
believe so my first question is and the
most important one
was it's possible that there is a group
of people serving for the russian secret
service who would fulfill this order
and he replied yes and i have to tell
you that lithuanian was not the only
person to whom i went
with this kind of questions i i have my
other you know friend i do not really
see him very often who lives in london
who is defector from groom military
intelligence uh victor suvorov he's a
popular writer he wrote several books
and i went to see him indeed i see him
for the first time i went to london to
see him precisely you know to to ask
this question and to look into his eyes
because it's important to look into you
know
a nice of a secret service person
uh to understand what he really thinks
and to ask him look uh you know i have
this problem victor i investigate i'm
investigating the the september 99
bombings i came to this particular
conclusions could you tell me where this
is possible
and he told me well of course it is
possible so what's what's wrong with you
why why are you asking this kind of
question i said well you know because
it's just difficult to believe that in
99 blah blah blah
i said well look and if you
if you receive this order would you
would you do it yeah what's the problem
so of course i would love the buildings
and i said well well okay what if your
friend is there
would you tell him that you are going to
go up the building before you blow up
the buildings no
no yuri you know i work for for the
russian secret service we have special
people you do not understand this don't
try to understand us you know this is
our job you know we we kill people our
buildings i mean this is our job that
okay fine uh your relative is there your
sister will you tell her no
okay your mother and father are there
will you tell them he said no
that okay and he has two children a
daughter and a son
okay victor
what if your children are there
and then he kind of
stopped and was sinking for several
seconds and he told me well
you know what
if my son alone would be there i
probably would blow up the building
but if my daughter as well i probably
won't
and at that point i realized that all my
questions are kind of stupid that i just
you know have to you know to follow the
the conclusions
that the fact that we are not able to
understand that the russian secret
service is blowing up buildings
this is actually our problem that we are
not able to understand because well
we're different
and uh you know when uh
when i am introduced as a friend of
alexandre litwinian i personally trying
to avoid this word and the reason for
this is that we once had conversa you
know we had many philosophical
conversations with lithuanian and one of
them was about friendship and he told me
look you know if you know that person
was working or is he is working for kgb
forgets about freud friend it's just i
mean we're different you do not
understand this we are different never
use the word french because all
population actually is divided for us
into two groups i will explain you
everything is it's divided into two
groups agents and objects
agents are those who are supplying us
with information so for example you are
my agent you are supplying me this
information like you know you were
telling me about the weather in boston
was how much the food is you know where
you live and said you're supplying me
with information you're my agent or you
might be an object a person against whom
i'm working
that's it that's that's
that's all what's exists and i feel sort
of how stupid and primitive it is i mean
how could you divide the whole
population i mean everybody including
your wife children family friends into
these two primitive categories and then
i realized that well you know
it's probably not so bad i mean it's
kind of simple
but it works i you you could approach
this rule to any person with whom you're
meeting or dealing not talking and this
this actually works you just have to be
a secret service member for this that's
it
so it's uh you know this these people
are very
very different and that's what i needed
for the book you see you may sit in your
room in your office in the library all
your life and try to to to understand
what's happening
with the
russian secret service or inside the
rich
secret service
but unless
you have this kind of insight
information these are not secrets these
are not really secrets right this is
just psychology you you have to
understand what those people are
so yes i uh in 1990 stanislav cavaroukin
made a cutting edge film no way to live
and um that was a gutsy thing i had the
the honor of being in i was the clown in
that movie
and uh it's my understanding is now an
elected official and how is he reacting
to this uh reversal of uh
freedom
well
you see the problem with of russia is
that
uh
the soviet union collapsed very quickly
in august of 91
and very quickly everybody saw that you
know the democracy is already there
and somehow everybody was thinking that
with the with democracy
prosperity will come as well
as quickly as the soviet union collapsed
and this of course for many reasons this
did not really happened uh at least
it happened for some people it didn't
happen for for majority of population
and then of course russia you know has a
history of a country being very corrupt
as we know
uh very poor especially if you go
outside cities
and uh
you know from 91 to 99
people live through a very very
difficult time
and some people saw that you know look
we had democracy for nine years that's
enough
we do not need it anymore it doesn't
work for russia it doesn't work
and that's that's the problem you see
that too many people and
you know many of them are educated
nice people so that well democracy is
not for russia we tried in 91 it did not
work
let's try something else
since no one actually understand what mr
putin is doing and mr
no one understands what mr putin is
doing because no one actually
understands that the corporation of
russian secret agents that the fsb
corporation took power and they are
ruling this country as corporation
uh because they are secret agents they
try to be secret they have called
official positions which are very
different no one actually is holding a
position as a secret agent colonel or
lieutenant colonel
or general right people do not really
understand that the fsb is controlling
the country at least they do not see
this way
they see a lot of retired fsb people who
are happening to be presidents or bank
presidents or
managers of huge corporations
but they do not see it as a kind of coup
d'or
uh and that's that's why a lot of people
unfortunately see that well probably
it's just you know a new period which
started after this uh
unpleasant democratic
period which
happened for nine years and uh maybe
russia will live now better especially
because of course prices for oil and gas
are much higher this allowed more money
for the budget
people seems to be living better than
they were living in 1991
so some of them are not complaining the
same way they were complaining before
we have the uh urban legend of the cia
weapons and drugs
compromise colluding corruption
i haven't read your book but do you go
into um victor booth though the weapons
guy and then the russian mafia and these
things we've heard about over the last
15 years in relation to your story in
the kgb
well uh i mean the fsb all right well
kgbf usually ironical people do not know
what the fsb is so it's i'm every time
i'm using the fsb i'm kind of telling
violence as this is the same
organization which
we know as a kgb but this is the same
organization same same people literally
same people no one actually retired or
was punished for crimes committed during
the soviet years
uh
we do know of course that russian mafia
exists we do know of course that there
is a huge corruption uh what's important
to understand and i i think again we do
not understand it because we do not
see just the top part of the iceberg we
do not really see what's under we do not
understand how much
uh the involvement of the russian secret
service into those structures structures
uh is and this is what involvement is
huge
and uh what what i basically is fair to
say that
uh the
especially now that the current russian
government allows as much mafia to exist
as they want them to exist
because
because we are talking about
dozens of thousands of people from the
russian secret service uh working out
both officially and unofficially as you
know
people who control economy and mafia in
russia of course is strong because they
they have
access to money
so they're dealing with those managers
who for this at the same time are
working for the russian city service so
there is no way uh the russian secret
service does not know who is
who are leaders of major mafia structure
structures of russia they do know this
they allow them to exist because that's
that's the way for them to
you know to to exist that's the way for
them to to
corrupt population to earn money as well
the same with terrorism the same with
terrorism i do not want to say that
every terrorist act which happens in
russia is
organized by the russian secret service
this is definitely not so there are
uh at least couple major terrorist acts
which were organized by by chechens uh
like the this one for example are
hostage takeover in in
september when they took that school
but
what the nordos for example uh event is
a very different one and is a very
questionable one and there is a lot of
information which is telling us that
there is a very good chance that the
russian secret service knew that the not
not or set a takeover is going to take
place so it's it's different every time
uh you know it's still the russian
secret service there are several groups
uh
you know there are military secret
service there is ffsb
uh
it's it's difficult to know everything
but uh but i think again it's fair to
say that the level of involvement of the
russian secret service in criminal
activity in russia in general
is underestimated by us
what can we as americans do about the
situation you describe and does it
present a threat to us
well as the first part i think is uh
easy to answer nothing
literally uh what i think are important
to do is to
understand the problem and to name the
problem
but what's uh
you know
russia is is a country which is very
difficult to influence it's a huge
country it's a rich it's rich country
and uh
you know when when you
have freedom of press in russia then of
course everything is much easier because
you have
you know journalistic community which
which usually helps each other and
that's how the truth comes out
internationally speaking uh when you do
not have freedom of press in russia then
it's very difficult to influence russia
because you may you know write letters
so make speeches uh as much as you want
but if there is
no reports about those events in russia
then you you are not actually
influencing russian public and opinion
at all
but uh but i think uh it is important to
to name the problem
and uh
at the same time i have to say that
the soviet union which we knew uh was a
very very strong country and it's
collapsed in 91 very quickly
russia which we are facing now is much
weaker than when the soviet union russia
indeed i believe is very weak country
militarily as well uh if you ask my
opinion i do not think that
russia introduces danger for the united
states in terms of
you know militarily but at the same time
uh
in 91 99 you see
we actually had a kind of strategically
at least a friend in in russia now we
lost this friend we do not have him
uh and this we have to understand that
these are people people who control
russia now they were working again for
kgb all their life and when they were
working for kgb living under the soviet
uh regime the united states was number
one enemies western europe was number
two enemy and that's how they see
unfortunately the state situation now
nothing changed for them they still
consider the united states as the mage
as a major enemy of russia
and uh that's why unfortunately there's
you know they probably will try to cause
as much uh problems to to america and to
the western world as they could and
traditionally they were involved in
selling weapons to official and
unofficially to questionable governments
and to
questionable countries
which are animals
foreign enemies of the united states
they are continuing to do so now we
could see it
they always are looking for a conflict
you see they they are not able to exist
without conflict because if there is no
conflict if russia is a peaceful
democratic country
you do not need the russian secret
service you don't need the fsb because
for all you know crime activity etc you
have other structures there is a police
structure which deals with crimes there
is a control intelligence which deals
with the spanish cases the fsb is an
organization
it's like a tobacco there is nothing
positive in this organization there is
not a single nice word you could say
about them uh
the country doesn't need them this
organization should be resolved uh
indeed this organization of course is
becoming stronger and stronger and
stronger
and in order to
you know to
in order to make the point that they
needed
they need to have conflicts both inside
russia and outside russia that's why you
have now a lot of this
stupid uh artificial
foreign conflict you have a russian uh
georgian conflict of georgian wine you
have russian polish conflict over
georgian beef uh you have russian
maldavian conflict over maldivian wine
uh you had uh
you know
conflict with britain over latvia's
murder of course uh you have conflict
with the united states because uh putin
stated compared to
bush or to hitler or
america to nazi germany i mean all those
conflicts are very artificial because
they they need them they they do not
really know how to exist in a in a
peaceful
peaceful environment uh they they need
something else
in your introduction you mentioned that
for the first time since world war ii we
have a country which has a intelligence
without a political control
almost uh i would say the closest it
comes it's the regime of chauchesco
was practically personal regime rather
than a regime of the communist party who
controlled to the minute details
this was
described in detail by patseppa in his
book red horizons he was a head of the
intelligence uh how do you see the
future developments political
developments in russia in lieu of such
uh possible
compass i believe i said no political
control but political ideology that's
that's the differences with communist
socialists you know nazis uh the fsb
people are usually asking well what's
what's what's the goal what's their
political agenda what's the ideology
we do not see it
we do not see it because it doesn't
exist they they want to control but they
do not really know
what the ideological base for this they
want to control because
uh they're controlling um countries
they're controlling money and that this
is the nature to control with again i'm
not specialist in churches but i i think
we could consider him to be a communist
i might be wrong
but
what
again what's uh
i i think the difference and the
importance is that uh again for the
first time we have
people who are trying to control without
actually having
an ideological goal for this there is no
ideological goal that it is this i do
not see it because putin is not a
communist what will happen
well what will happen i think it's easy
easy easy to predict uh there are going
to be elections in 2008 and uh you know
every every time i was using the word
elections uh recently you know i feel
kind of uncomfortable because i i knew
that this is the wrong word because
there are not going there are not going
to be elections in in russia in 2008 we
all know this uh it's uh
and then i
found uh indeed i found this word in
portugal when i was you know
having a
promotional touring portugal for my book
i found the word i think the right word
is selection
uh the the russian secret service the
corporation which is ruling the country
now which is controlling situation now
will select the next president for
russia and they will select him by 2008
and they will you know officially elect
him through this process of election uh
which is a very
you know
i mean not really an election process
anymore and i think uh it's going to be
a member of corporation when people are
asking how much
power president putin has now i think
the right answer is
as much as the president of corporation
has so he has a lot of power but
probably corporation still has
enough power to to
control him to maneuver him to direct
him redirect him to take him down even
if they
really want to
uh and uh that's probably going to
happen in 2008 they will select the next
person uh
i think it's going to be from the
corporation of the fsb meaning that it's
going to be literally a general of the
fsb who is going to be promoted to the
position of the president uh in 2008 and
i think that it's going to be worse than
what we're having now with mr putin i
will explain you why this system of
corporate rule uh over russia actually
was
made not by the fsb ironically it was
made by russian oligarch in 96 in 96
they
gave them money to support president
yeltsin and president yeltsin with us
two percent of popularity
finished uh finally with 52 percent of
wars uh because of this money and for
four years from 96 to 2000 the
corporation of russian oligarchs
actually was ruling russia
in 2000 putin was
selected first and then promoted to this
position of the president by two groups
one was the russian oligarchs who uh
unfortunately or mistakenly was thinking
that they are the only people who are
supporting putin what they didn't know
that there is another group which indeed
is more powerful than they are this is a
group of corporation of the russian
secret service
uh so as soon as putin became the
president he actually stopped to be
loyal to oligarchs and
moved further and closer and closer to
the corporation of the russian secret
service people and he started to promote
to major political positions
uh other officers from the kgb uh there
is different statistic uh i
there was a statistic that between 70
and 80 percent of all major government
and political positions are taken by the
fsb personnel now uh live a couple days
ago an article was published in a german
newspaper that this percentage is is low
that it's just 46
but even even even if this even even if
we take this lower figure 43 percent uh
it's still very high uh it's this means
that the russian secret service is
effectively controlling the country and
uh
that's why we see this move uh in
putin's behavior from 2000 to 2006 he is
doing what his corporation wants him to
do uh in the beginning uh he was loyal
to two forces to the fsb and two russian
oligarchs by the end of his turn
in 2007 he is loyal just to this one
group
the russian secret service and the next
one who is going to be selected in 2008
will be loyal just to the fsb so it's
it's going to be worse than what we're
having now
but now we have time for one more so
that's the final question then what what
is the background of the explosive
growth of the neo-nazi movement in
russia and how does it relate to the the
government overall is it
an enemy or is it reflecting the spirit
of the government itself well uh first
of all i think it's all started to
actually in like 91 it started with
freedom with general freedom with uh
you know general understanding in russia
that well it's the time when you do what
you want
uh i i personally
maybe i'm wrong again uh this doesn't
mean that i i'm
quite sure that i'm right but i
personally do not think that in multi in
a multinational country and russia is a
multinational country
you might may have a very strong
national movement i do not see it this
way this movement exists uh
the government does allow it to exist
but i think they allow it to exist
because they control it
you see every time they try to prohibit
something or to kill something whether
we are talking about people or an
organization
uh this is an indication for us that
they are not able to control it if they
allow to uh
if they allow mr zirinowski
to exist this means that they control
him if they allow a nazi party to exist
this means that they control them if
they
try not to allow uh
limonos party which is another kind of
national party to exist this means that
they're not able to control it that's
it's it's very simple for them the most
important thing is not how bad the
organization is how damaging it is for
them it's important whether they control
it or not if they control mafia they
they allow them to exist if a certain
mafia group cannot be controlled they
killed that's that's that's how to
decide that's how they decide whom to
allow to exist and whom to destroy the
same with khadarkovsky in economy they
made a decision or this is what they
understanding that they're not able to
control khadarkovsky so they destroyed
the whole empire of uh yukos because
they were not able to control it or they
were afraid that they are not able to
control it
great well thank you very much yuri that
was terrific
[Applause]
blowing up russia yerry felstinsky is
the author of several books including
the bolsheviks and the left srs and big
bosses
for more visit felstinsky.com
[Music]